what is genocide what are the defining
characteristics of genocide
dealing with genocide is a difficult
thing when it comes to the definition um
there is a definition of december 1948
u.n uh convention on the
prevention and punishment of genocide is
considered the sort of major
document of definition in the
definitional sense of genocide and it
emphasizes
you know the intentional
destruction
you know of
an ethnic
national racial or religious group those
are the four groups again
comma as such and what that means
basically is destroying
the group as a group
there's a kind of beauty
in human diversity
and
different groups of people you know
estonians
you know tribe of native americans south
african tribes you know the rohingya in
myanmar there's a kind of beauty
humanity recognizes in the
distinctiveness of those groups
uh you know this was a notion that
emerges really with romanticism after
the french revolution than the beginning
of the 19th century
with herder mostly and this beauty of
these groups then
um
you know is what is under attack
in genocide
um
and it's with intent you know the idea
is that the it's intentional destruction
so this is a kind of
you know
analogy to first degree second degree
and third degree murder right first
degree murder you know you're out to
kill this person and you plan it and you
go out and you do it
right that's intent
right manslaughter is not intent you end
up doing the same thing but it's
different
so
um
you know the the major
person behind the definition was a man
named raphael lemkin i don't know if you
heard his name or not but he was a
polish jewish
jurist
who came
you know from poland came to the united
states during the war
and had been a kind of um
crusader
for recognizing genocide it's a word
that he created by the way
and he coined the term in 1943 and then
published it in 1944 for the first time
geno meaning people inside meaning
killing right and so lemkin then had
this term and he pushed hard to have it
recognized and it was in the un
convention so that's
the rough definition the problem with is
the definition
the problems with the definition are
several
uh you know one of them is um
is it just these four groups you know
racial religious ethnic or national
see this comes right out of the war and
what's in people's minds in 1948
are jews poles russians yugoslavs
sometimes who were killed by the nazis
that's what's in their mind but there
are other groups too if you think about
it you know who are
killed
social groups or political groups and
and that was not allowed in the
convention
meaning
for a lot of different reasons the
soviets were primary among them
they didn't want other kinds of groups
let's say kulaks for example
uh to be considered that's a social
group
uh or peasants which is a social group
so or a political group i mean let's
take a group um
uh you know communists killed
groups of people
but non-communists also killed groups of
people in indonesia in
1965-66 they killed you know i don't
know exactly but roughly 600 000
indonesian communists well is that
genocide or not
you know and my point of view it is
genocide although it's indonesians
killing indonesians
and we have the same problem with the
cambodian genocide i mean we talk about
a cambodian genocide
but most of the people killed in the
cambodian genocide were other cambodians
they give it the name they're ready to
recognize this genocide because they
also killed some other peoples meaning
the vietnamese
ham people who are
you know muslim
muslim smaller muslim people in the area
and a few others so the question then
becomes
well does it have to be a different
nationality or ethnic group a religious
group for it to be genocide and my
answer is no
you need to expand the definition it's a
little bit like with our constitution
we've got a constitution i mean but we
don't live in the end of the 18th
century right we live in the 21st
century and so you have to update the
constitution over the centuries and
similarly the genocide convention needs
updating too so that's how i work with
the definition so this is this invention
was it an invention this beautiful idea
romantic idea that there's groups of
people and the group is united by some
unique characteristics
that was an invention in human history
that this idea
not not the css individual senses it was
uh i mean it's not it you know there are
things are are always constructed at one
fashion or another and that is in the
construction you know more or less
represents the reality and what the
reality is always much more complicated
than the construction or the invention
of the of of a term or a concept or a
way of thinking about a nation
right and and this way of thinking of
nations you know as
as again you know groups of religious
linguistic
um
uh um
not political necessarily
but cultural entities
is something that was essentially
invented yes yes i mean you know if you
like there are no germans in the 17th
century there are no italians in the
17th century right they're only there
after you know the invention
of the nation which comes
uh again mostly as uh out of the french
revolution and in the romantic movement
a man named
johim johann gottfried fund-herder right
who was the really the first one who
sort of went around collected people's
languages and collected their sayings
and their dances and their folk ways and
stuff and said isn't this cool you know
that they're estonians and that they're
latvians and that they're these other
these interesting different peoples
who don't even know necessarily
that they're different peoples right
that comes a little bit later
right once the concept is invented then
people start to say hey we're nations
too
you know and the germans decide they're
a nation and they unify and the italians
discover they're a nation and they unify
instead of being you know
florentines and romans and
and uh you know sicilians
but then beyond nations there's uh
political affiliations all those kinds
of things it's fascinating that you know
you start you look at the early homo
sapiens and then there's obviously
tribes right and then
that's very concrete that's a geographic
location and it's a small group of
people and you have warring tribes
probably connected to just um limited
resources but it's fascinating to think
that that is then taken to
the space of ideas to where you can
create a group
at first to um
to appreciate its beauty
you create a group
based on language based on um
maybe even so political philosophical
ideas religious ideas all those kinds of
things and then that naturally then
leads to
getting angry at groups right and making
them the other and then hatred right
that comes more
towards the end of the 19th century you
know with the influence of darwin i mean
you can't blame darwin for it but
neo-darwin darwinians you know who start
to talk about you know the competition
between nations the natural competition
the weak ones
fall away the strong winds get ahead
you know you get this sort of
combination also with um you know modern
anti-semitism and with racial thinking
you know the racial thinking at the end
of the 19th century is very powerful
so now
you know at the end of the 19th century
versus the beginning and uh you know
you know the middle of the 19th century
you know you can be a german and be a
jew and there's no contradiction
yeah as long as you speak the language
and you you know you dress and think and
act and share the culture by the end of
the 19th century people say no no
you know they're not germans they're
jews they're different they have
different blood they have different they
don't say genes yet but you know that's
sort of a
a sense of people and that's when
you know there's a sense of superiority
too and inferiority
yeah you know that they're inferior to
us yeah you know and um
and that we're the strong ones and we
have to you know and hitler by the way
just adopts this
hook line and sinker i mean they're a
whole series of thinkers at the end of
the 19th and beginning of 20th century
who he cites in mein kampf you know
which is written in the early 1920s
that
you know basically
pervades this racial thinking so
nationalism changes so nationalism in
and of itself is not bad
i mean it's not bad you know to share
culture and language and
and you know folk ways and
and a sense of common belonging and
nothing bad about it inherently but then
what happens is it becomes
you know frequently is used and becomes
especially on fascism
becomes
dangerous
you